um okay so well
uh welcome everybody um
uh to uh today's colloquium which
obviously is
at uh at an unusual time so it's a real
pleasure to have
uh mark zandry here um uh
mark is uh is on the faculty at
princeton
uh he has uh he has a very distinguished
career
you know starting work in in
classical cryptography but but
increasingly dipping into
into uh the quantum aspects of this
object and so i can't
uh you know think of uh anyone better to
talk to us about
uh post quantum cryptography so thanks
mark
uh yeah thank you for the introduction
and and uh thanks to everyone for
accommodating my schedule
and having this being at an unusual time
um so should i get started uh yes please
um okay all right so um
i'll start with a whirlwind tour of um
the history of crypto uh so crypto is a
really ancient practice
dating back about 4 000 years um
sort of the first phase i'll call
pre-modern crypto
and basically this was characterized um
by
uh this era was characterized by a tug
of war between the code makers and code
breakers
and it was this you know continuous
cycle of designing code
a clever attack to break it design a new
code a new code etc
um something uh really important
change though in the the 1900s
i mean there really actually three
things that um really
revolutionize crypto uh one is
uh technology and specifically computers
uh the introduction of technology into
cryptography
uh helped in cryptanalysis efforts
during world war ii
um and and beyond and it also allowed
the uh code makers to move beyond
the pencil and paper type ciphers that
could be done by hand that had
characterized
crypto for for ages um and by using more
complex codes
this made the cryptanalysis uh
exponentially more difficult
uh the other uh big thing that changed
in crypto was the introduction of
formalism
uh so now we have precise definitions of
what it means to be secure
and we have rigorous proofs of security
and as a result of
of um this today really hacks are not
usually the result of crypto being
broken but they're instead the results
of
social engineering bad practices traffic
analysis things like that the
the crypto is not the um weak link
um and the other big thing was the
realization
that cryptography wasn't just about
encryption
um and you know there's all sorts of
things there's public key
cryptography which allows for parties
who've never met
and don't have a shared secret key to be
able to securely communicate
there's things like zero knowledge
proofs how to prove a
theorem without actually revealing the
proof multi-party computation
how to um have a bunch of mutually
distrusting
individuals compute a joint function on
their inputs and then
the list goes on and on
um so this is this is modern crypto
which uh has characterized crypto for
the last
several decades um and what we're
starting to enter now is the the
next phase of crypto which is post
quantum crypto
um and uh
this this phase will be characterized by
the emergence of quantum computers which
you know seem like they're they're
coming and
uh quantum computers will really require
us to visit
all three of these
main features of modern cryptography so
the enhanced computational power of a
quantum computer will mean that codes
are broken
we'll now need to reason about quantum
computation to in order to justify the
security of our crypto systems
and on on the on the other hand you know
maybe by running a quantum computer
there's
um that can be achieved that were never
before possible
all right so for this talk i'll be
giving um
a brief overview of the the threat that
quantum computers
um bring to cryptography um so mainly
focusing on the first two things and
i'll just
briefly mention um the new applications
um at the very end
um so the first thing is
i need to clarify what i mean by we now
have rigorous proofs of security
um so you know the the most famous uh
problem in computer science is this p
versus np problem
basically whether the ability to verify
solutions efficiently mean you can
compute the solutions from scratch
um and the fact is that we don't know
the answer to this question
uh but it turns out that if it were
resolved in the positive meaning if p
were actually equal to np
it turns out that most crypto would be
impossible
so the entire uh field of cryptography
is
based on the widely believed but
unproven assumption
that at least uh p is not equal to np
that there
are problems that you can verify that um
uh
but you can nevertheless not um find
solutions from scratch um and right so
so
most crypto relies on p not equal mp and
in fact it will rely on even
more specific uh computational
assumptions the hardness of specific
instances
such as the hardness of factoring
discrete log
certain hard problems on lattices like
finding shortest vectors
inverting particular hash functions and
so forth
um so all of crypto or not all but most
of crypto is based on
some assumption like this um and what
this means is we have to really
clarify what we mean by a crypto
security proof so here's what i'll call
the fundamental formula of modern
cryptography
which is that a cryptosecurity proof
has three components so the first is
some computational assumption
let's say the hardness of factoring
[Music]
and then a precise security definition
of what you're trying to achieve
so a formalization of what it means to
be a secure encryption scheme
or whatever and then a re
uh something called a reduction which
shows how to
um shows that solving p to solve p
suffices to break d uh or
put another way if you can attack the
crypto system
then you are able to solve the
underlying
presumably hard computational problems
so if you're able to break the
encryption scheme
according to the security definition d
then you can transform that algorithm
into an algorithm that um factors
integers or something like that
um so the the the problem when we move
to this third era of cryptography
where we are starting to consider
quantum computers
is that the typical literature only
considers
um the classical versions of all of
these three ingredients
so when we move to a setting with
quantum computers and we want
to justify the security of our crypto
system against an adversary
who may have at their disposal quantum
computer we need a well we need to first
make sure that the
assumption is actually secure against a
quantum computer so we need a post
quantum assumption
this requires us asking which
assumptions are still plausible once we
have a quantum computer
um we need a precise security definition
uh for quantum attacks and this raises
the question of what kind of quantum
attacks are possible
um and then we need a reduction um or
that transforms an attacker for our post
quantum definition into an
attacker against our starting assumption
um and in this reduction we need to then
reason about quantum computation not
just classical computation so all three
of these ingredients
um need to be revisited once we move to
the quantum setting
um so first i'll just briefly talk so
in this talk i'll talk about all three
of these ingredients um i'll start
just by briefly talking about
cryptographic assumptions
uh so there are sort of three categories
of cryptographic assumptions
for our purposes the first is going to
be
these ones on the left here such as
factoring in discrete log
that appear to be hard for classical
computation
but due to schwarz algorithm
it turns out that these uh problems are
actually easy on a quantum computer
so it once we're moving to uh
post-quantum cryptography
uh we can no longer base security off of
these assumptions
because they no longer hold so that's
the first category
uh the second category are um
you know concrete hash functions or
block ciphers things like that that are
not based on algebra and these these
will
be crucial in a post quantum setting
they are not
broken by quantum computers but it turns
out that these have limited applications
many of the
amazing applications that cryptographers
have
discovered over the last two decades
cannot be achieved by
by this category and so the final
category
are these algebraic type of assumptions
uh like solving multivariate equations
computing esogenes between elliptic
curves hard problems on lattices
that appeared to be resistant to quantum
computers
and also are capable of achieving all of
these amazing applications and and
and because of uh the ability to
achieve these applications while
resisting quantum attacks most of the
attention has been
placed on these assumptions and in
particular uh
lattices have been sort of the main
focus of
post quantum cryptography
i'll also just briefly mention that
there's more than just shors algorithm
um there are some partial attacks such
as grover's algorithm and cooper berg's
algorithm
that apply to different subsets of of
these problems
that weaken them but don't break them
and you can usually compensate
for for these attacks by
increasing parameter sizes
um so that's that's more or less all i
wanted to say about
cryptographic assumptions i just wanted
to mention a key takeaway
from all this is that essentially all of
the total quantum attacks the ones that
render the computational assumptions um
completely broken
um essentially all of them are
uh view the assumption as an instance of
something called period finding or the
hidden subgroup problem over of billion
groups
so so schwarz algorithm for factoring a
discrete log basically views
uh you know somehow shows that if you
can
find the period of a function you can
factor integers
and the way that this is done is you
define this function
f of a that just takes g to the a mod
n uh if you find the period of this
function
f uh well then if you raise g to the
period over two
what you get is a square root of one and
it turns out that computing square roots
of one mod a composite allows you to
factor
uh and discrete log you can also view as
a period finding sort of a
multi-dimensional period finding
where your input is the a
two-dimensional
vector uh when you define your function
like this
and it turns out that the the period of
this function actually immediately tells
you the discrete log
the value a such that g to the a equals
h
um so so all the total quantum attacks
to
view whatever assumption they're
attacking as an instance of period
finding
and the ones that resist quantum
computer uh quantum attacks
uh we don't know of any reduction to
period finding over a billion groups
okay so so that i with that out of the
way the
the rest of the talk is really going to
focus on
the the other two ingredients of a
crypto security proof
which are our definitions and reductions
and the the point is going to be to
demonstrate
that you know just basing your
cryptosystem on lattices which
you know presumably resist quantum
attacks just basing
your cryptosystem on you know any post
quantum assumption
it's not enough and you really need to
be careful um
when when you're trying to justify the
security against quantum on computers
all right um so i'll give uh several
examples
that uh will hopefully sort of
illustrate
uh sort of the key challenges faced in
post-quantum cryptography
uh the first example
will is going to be something called
pseudorandom generators
um so a pseudorandom generator is
a deterministic function g
that takes as inputs and bits
outputs and bits for some m greater than
n so it expands its input
um and yet what we want uh and here i'll
just review sort of the classical case
so from the moment nothing nothing
quantum is going
on uh what we want is that this output
uh looks random now of course it
cannot be truly random because it has
only n bits of entropy from the input if
assuming the input is
random and you know that the output is
m bits long for m greater than n so it
can't be truly random
uh but the hope is that it can't be
distinguished from random
by any uh efficient adversary
so we say that g is a secure
pseudo-random generator
if for all efficient classical
adversaries because we're in the
classical setting
for now uh you know basically
uh this this condition in the green box
just says that
no classical algorithm can distinguish
a truly random y
to the random output y from g of x for a
random x
all right and and we we denote efficient
classical time
algorithms by this uh we call it
probabilistic polynomial time
we allow um the adversary to be
randomized
when we denote this ppt
um all right and just a bit of
terminology
the the difference here for for a
particular algorithm
the difference between the probability
that it outputs one
when given a random output versus a
output of the generator
uh we'll call this epsilon the advantage
okay um so that's that's classical
pseudorandomness
uh and now here's a question that that
you may wonder
uh suppose i have a pseudo-random
generator with some
stretch like let's suppose it even just
expands the input by a single bit
uh but for some reason i want to
generate more randomness you know maybe
i still don't have quite enough
randomness to suit my needs
uh well it turns out that you can expand
the randomness but just by repeated
application of the
generator so i have my n-bit input
i expand it via the pseudorandom
generator to get n plus one bits
and then i take n of those bits uh which
is
happens to be the domain of the
pseudo-random generator again so i feed
it through the generator again
and get n plus one bits and then i add
the one bit left over from before and i
get n plus two bits and you know you can
keep doing this as many times as you
like
uh to generate as much uh
pseudorandomness as you want
and we have a classical theorem that
says that this works
that if the pseudorandom generator is
secure even if it just
uh provides with provides you with one
extra bit
of of pseudorandomness then repeated
application
will will also be pseudorandom
um so so let's go through the the proof
of this
uh this is sort of a like a classical
standard proof technique
uh so the way we prove security
in the quantum side or sorry in the in
classical cryptography
is by contradiction so
um we we assume toward contradiction
that we have that actually our new
pseudo-random generator that expanded by
two bits
we assume that it's insecure um which
means that there is a
ppt adversary a with some noticeable
advantage in distinguishing
uh random from pseudorandom for for this
new generator g2
and what we're going to try to do from
this is arrive at a contradiction
by showing how to transform this
adversary
a into an adversary for the underlying
pseudorandom generator which we assumed
was secure
all right um so the way we're going to
do this is by something called a hybrid
argument and this is the
the bread and butter of of crypt crypto
security proofs
so i'm going to define an experiment or
hybrid zero
uh which is just the case where i feed
the adversary a pseudorandom output so
an actual output of g2
on a random input and i'm just going to
define
p0 as the probability that the adversary
outputs one
in this case i'll define a second hybrid
a hybrid two
uh which is the the random case where
where a's is given a uniformly random
string and i'm going to find p2
as the probability that uh be equal that
the
adversary outputs one in this case
and then finally i'm going to define
this intermediate hybrid which is sort
of
interpolating between hybrid zero and
hybrid two
where the way the adversary's input is
derived
is the first n plus one bits are the
output of the pseudo-random generator on
a truly random input
and then the final bit is uniformly
random
right so so i've sort of replaced the
first prg
with random but i haven't gone all the
way to replacing the entire
input to the adversary with random
um okay so so what does this hybrid
allow us to do
well first we know that by virtue of our
adversary a being a distinguisher
uh an attacker against the pseudo-enemy
generator g2
we know that p2 minus p0 have to be
large that is just
you know by the assumption that the
attacker is an actual attacker
p0 and p2 correspond to the exact things
that our attacker is trying to
distinguish
so we know p0 and p2 are far apart
we don't actually know anything about p1
we're given
nothing about the adversary other than
the fact that it is an adversary
and all that tells us is that p0 minus
p2 are far
um so we don't know anything about p1 uh
but what we can do is we can sort of
break
into two cases so one case is that
p1 is somewhat far from p0
and the other case is that p1 is
somewhat far from p2
by the triangle inequality one of these
two must hold
right because p0 and v2 are far apart
p1 can't be simultaneously close to both
of them
so we know one of these are true and in
either case we can
use we can use the fact that p1 is far
from p0 or the fact that p1 is far from
p2
to derive an adversary for the
underlying
generator so in the left case
our address 3 looks like this and in the
right case register looks like this
uh maybe i won't explain this but the
intuition is we just you know
the difference between these adjacent
hybrids was one application of the
pseudo-energy generator
and if we were able to distinguish the
adjacent hybrids we can sort of isolate
the the one difference and use that to
um to break the underlying pseudorandom
generator g
um but the you know so the key takeaway
is that in either case no matter what
happens with hybrid one
um in one of the two cases we're able to
get an advantage in attacking g
okay so um so that's
uh classical the classical proof
of this theorem uh now what happens when
we move
to the quantum setting what happens when
we now want to introduce
quantum computers into the mix uh well
so first our starting assumption we need
to update to the
assumption that our original
pseudo-random generator is secure
against quantum computers
um right so so we can update our
definition of what it means to be a
secure pseudorandom generator
uh basically you just replace any
instance of
probabilistic or classical you just
replace it with quantum
um right so instead of ppt we have qpt
where q stands for quantum
right so this is this is straightforward
um and then it turns out that we
can also lift our theorem from the
classical setting to the quantum setting
saying that if g our little one bit
um stretch pseudo-ram generator if it is
post-quantum secure so if it resists
quantum attacks
then it also resists then this then the
generator g2 which expanded by two bits
also resists quantum attacks
and the the proof is actually
essentially identical so here's the same
exact slide as before
except that um i've you know inserted
cues
in the the necessary place so you know
we start from
we prove by contradiction so we suppose
that g2 is insecure against the quantum
attacker uh so that means that there
exists a quantum polynomial time
algorithm a with a non-negligible
advantage epsilon
and you know everything everything we do
is is is the same
uh except that the only difference is
you know b
is running a is sort of a as running our
original attacker as a subroutine
and since the subroutine is quantum now
b has to be a quantum attack against g
um but otherwise the proof is literally
the same
um and uh this this this um the fact
that this
is that the proof is the same um
is actually part of sort of a a broader
principle
um and the the point is that our proof
of security
for g2 actually didn't care
how how the adversary that we started
from worked internally
um all i cared about was that it broke
the
it broke the uh pseudorandomness of the
generator
um which which just meant that it had a
non-negligible advantage that it had a
noticeable pro advantage in
distinguishing random from
pseudorandom but it actually didn't care
at all
about um how a worked internally
so a could have been a classical
computer you know taking
a random or pseudorandom y and
outputting a bit b
it could have been a quantum computer or
it could have been something even
crazier it could have uh
you know been using time close time-like
curves
or even just magic it didn't matter any
basically any
thing that happened inside the box is
irrelevant
um for the proof
and this is uh something that is
sometimes referred to as
um a black box proof uh and this is
uh pretty common in in in crypto
and it's actually curiously it's a it's
a consequence of our inability to reason
about polynomial time computation
is that we have to prove uh we have to
prove security in this way
where we we sort of take an attacker
treat them as a black box because we
don't know how to actually reason about
polynomial time computation and just
sort of use
the the input output behavior of the
attacker in order to solve our our
underlying problem
um and so the the key takeaway from this
is that as long as the reduction treats
the
adversary uh the supposed adversary that
we assumed for contradiction
as long as the reduction treats the
adversary
as a non-interactive black box so just
gets an input produces an output it's
not you know sending messages back and
forth
um we only run it a single time and
treat it as a black box
probably the reduction works in the
quantum setting i don't know that
there's necessarily a
complete uh rigorous theorem but at
least as intuition
um this this should probably
hold and so this captures things like
the the hybrid argument that we just saw
and as well as many of the uh well-known
results throughout crypto
um now throughout the talk i'm going to
keep updating this key takeaway
i'm adding adding uh more nuance to this
because there it turns out that there
are some times where
where things break down um
and so so you know the you know the for
this takeaway
um you know really crucially will rely
on the fact that the box is
non-interactive in a single run
all right um
so let's move on to the
second example which is
uh encryption
uh so here's i i won't
formally define like what an encryption
scheme
is but i'll just define what it means
for an encryption scheme to be
secure and the
way we define security is by the
following game and i'll elaborate on
sort of the
why security is defined this way in a
moment but let me just go over the game
so we imagine for encryption that the
adversary
that's trying to break the encryption
scheme is playing a game with a
challenger
the first thing the adversary does is
submits two messages and zero m1
and then the the challenger chooses a
random key
k for the encryption scheme chooses a
random bit b
and then encrypts using the key k
uh the the message selected by the bit b
and sends the resulting cipher text c
back to the adversary
our adversary then tries to break
basically just tries to tell which of
the two messages
was encrypted so they send a guess b
prime
back for b and we say that they win if b
equals b prime
the definite and the definition that we
have is that ink is one time
secure so it's secure for a single um
encrypting uh
you know one time only um if
for all polynomial time adversaries the
adversary
can't do better than random guessing
they can always flip a random bit for b
prime and win with probability a half
um and uh the scheme is secure if
an efficient adversary can't do much
better
all right we say it's one time because
we're only ever seeing
in a single a single cipher text um you
need to update this
uh definition if you wanted to see
multiple ciphertexts
and now let me uh go over why we define
security
in this way because it'll actually be
important in a couple slides
so um for for anyone who hasn't seen
crypto definitions like this before uh
the question is why why does the
adversary get to choose the message
after all the adversary is trying to
break the scheme and learn what the
message is why why are we allowing the
adversary to choose the message
and the reason is that we we want
the scheme to be secure for any source
of messages
maybe it's english text maybe it's video
files
etc we could have had a separate we
could have imagined a definition with
sort of a separate entity
for um sampling the messages but it's
sort of
uh cleaner to to just um sort of
group that entity together with the
adversary
um and there actually is precedent for
um the adversary actually having
influence on the messages
um as one example
um during world war ii british
intelligence um would actually ask
um the military to lay mines
uh in order to to lay mines in a
particular location
and then they would have some uh guess
that when the uh when the enemy
was communicating that they might have
been talking about the location where
the mines were laid
um so so there's actually precedent for
allowing the adversary influence on the
message
and plus it's mathematically cleaner to
sort of consider the
um everything as one entity
there's also the part that the adversary
you know maybe
uh has some side information about the
messages maybe
you know the administrator knows the the
recipient or
some contents and the adversary's goal
might not be to learn the entire message
but just to learn
you know one piece like when is the
attack going to happen or something like
that
and the the point is that uh basically
what this definition does is it
um collapses all these different
considerations down into a single
polynomial time
adversary who knows everything about the
message
except for one bit namely whether it's
m0 or m1 and all the adversaries trying
to do is on that single bit
um so okay so so that's that's
um classical encryption now what happens
when we move to the quantum setting
um well there's a straightforward
generalization
of of um classical encryption which i'll
just call
post quantum security where we did the
same thing as we did in the
pseudorandom generator case where we
just replaced
the polynomial time uh
the classical polynomial time adversary
with a quantum polynomial time
adversary so this is sort of the most
natural thing to do
um but there's there's another way that
you could define
um security which i will call
a fully quantum security where
not only are we allowing the adversary
to be quantum
but we're actually allowing the
adversary's messages with
the challenger to be quantum so right if
the adversary is
you know the rely on the adversary to
choose the message well now that he's a
quantum adversary maybe it makes sense
to allow the adversary to choose quantum
messages
um and and there's some subtleties in
actually getting a sensible definition
um that i only touch on so so all of
this here is informal that's why i have
these asterisks
here um you know there's some design
choices in coming up with
what act you know what actually makes
the sensible definition
but you know uh at least to a first
order approximation why couldn't we have
allowed the adversary
to send a superposition of pairs of
messages instead of just
you know two classical messages and then
they then the adversary gets
the encryption of um you know one half
of the superposition back
and their goal is to tell which one uh
so i'll call this full quantum security
um so you know now the question is
you know which definition do we actually
want which one makes sense
and i don't think there's a universal
right answer here
but instead which definition you use
will probably depend on your use case
and what kind of attacks you're
thinking might be possible uh so for
example
if your honest users the actual
you know communicating parties are
classical
and they are only interacting over
you know a classical uh network
and your adversary is just remote
somewhere else on this classical network
running a quantum device locally
well in this case it seems rather weird
to
imagine the adversary influencing the
honest parties enough
that the honest parties encrypt the
quantum message right because you know
they're classical they're only
communicating classically how
how on earth is the adversary going to
somehow cause them
to encrypt a quantum message when they
don't even have quantum capabilities
uh so in this case um
[Music]
you know pos quantum security is likely
efficient
um on the other hand uh if your honest
users are quantum
uh maybe because you're using this
encryption scheme and sort of a higher
level
quantum protocol um or maybe you're
actually allowing a to have physical
access
to the honest users maybe the the
encryption is happening on the smart
card and the app store actually
gets physical access to it um
now maybe you need full quantum security
uh because maybe now they're
it could be realistic uh potentially you
know we don't have quantum computers yet
we don't know what kind of attacks will
be there
but it could be plausible
in some of these cases that an attacker
could um
actually cause the honest users to
encrypt superpositions
um right
so um okay so so which definition you
use
will probably depend on your use case
and uh there's
there's no universal right answer
um so now the question is uh
you know we have these classical proof
techniques
for proving the security of various
crypto objects
which version do they give us do they
give us post quantum security or full
quantum security
um so here's here's a standard way to
build an encryption scheme as an example
this is something called a stream
cipher so we we
have a secret key k and the way we
encrypt our message is we first run the
key k through a pseudorandom generator
to just get a long pseudo-random string
and then we extort it with the message
and classically we have a theorem that
this works
so our theorem is that if g is a secure
pseudorandom generator
then um then the encryption scheme is
one time secure according to our
definition
and the the proof is um another simple
hybrid argument
we we assume the encryption scheme is
insecure which means that there is an
efficient
attacker with a noticeable advantage
and we define two hybrids so hybrid zero
corresponds to
the the sort of real experiment for
encryption
where the adversary actually gets
encryption of mb
we know just by the the fact that our
assumed adversary a
is an attacker for the encryption scheme
that um the probability their output b
prime matches b is one half plus epsilon
this is just
by definition of what it means to be an
attacker
on the other hand we can consider a
different experiment
where the way we encrypt is rather than
using
k and expanding it into a long pseudon
string gfk
we just replaced that long pseudorandom
string with a truly random string
and x or that with mb
i'm in hybrid one though note that
random string x or mb is just a random
string
uniformly random and independent of the
choice of b
so as a consequence no matter what the
adversary does in hybrid one
the probability b equals b prime is
exactly a half
and so what we can do is we can easily
take the fact that these two hybrids
have a
have an epsilon difference um between
the probabilities that b
prime is equal to b and we can use that
to construct an adversary
uh capital b uh with advantage epsilon
that actually breaks the underlying prg
um so when we move to the quantum
setting we'll we'll start with a
post-quantum prg so summer prg is secure
against post-quantum
attackers um and well actually
if you if you if the definition of
security uses post-quantum security so
quantum attacker but classical
interaction everything works
again it's you know you just basically
update
all instances of probabilistic
polynomial time to quantum polynomial
time
and the reason is basically the same as
what we
what we had before with the
pseudo-random generator case
that the the proof doesn't care how a
works internally as long as it has a
non-negligible advantage
um and so we also get you know our
classical reductions which trivially
lifts to give us a post-quantum
reduction
on the other hand this uh scheme
does not actually give us a full quantum
encryption scheme we can actually prove
this um and here's like one
one concrete attack that you could you
could do so
remember in the full quantum um case our
attacker is allowed
to create superpositions over pairs of
messages
so we create a superposition over m
comma 0.
so uniform superposition all messages
get the same weight in the sort of the
first
nested register and the second register
is all zeros
um so if we're in the case where the
challenger flips a bit b
equals zero um in this case we encrypt
the left register so
what gets x or with m is g of k and
since we're in the uniform superposition
this g of k x or m just basically
permutes
all of the the values of m and actually
what ends up happening is we're still in
the uniform superposition overall
messages
on the other hand of b equals one um
what gets encrypted is zero just this uh
basically single classical message zero
and so what the address theory sees
season response is g
of k for you know a random key k
um and and we can easily distinguish
these you know uniform superposition
if we were to apply the hadamard
transformation will just give us the l0
string
where um sort of this uh quantity even
though it's a random string
once you apply the when you apply the
hadamard you actually also get a
you get essentially also a random string
um so you can you just by applying
hadamard and measuring
here you'll get zero and here you'll get
a random string
and so you can easily distinguish these
two cases
uh um so so the question is then like
what went wrong like
why why doesn't the classical security
proof
lift to the full quantum setting and the
the reason is that the adversary is no
longer a black box of classical
interaction
yeah we might still try to treat the
adversaries of black box
but our new adversary for the
um for the full quantum security
encryption scheme
is exchanging quantum messages right it
sends a superposition over pairs of
messages
and gets a superposition of encrypted
messages in return
um so we've we've changed not only the
computational model of the adversary
which
you know to a first order approximation
doesn't enter into the crypto proofs
but we've also changed the the model of
interaction
and um the the classical security proof
actually crucially it turned
uh you know sort of imp implicit in this
in the fact that our encryption scheme
is not fully quantum secure
um it's it turns out that the classical
security proof crucially
relied on the fact that the classical
adversary was only
making classical interaction once we
allow the quantum interaction
things break and so the the
so here i'm going to update the takeaway
from before
to say that as long as the adversary as
long as the reduction treats the
adversary as a single run black box
um but potentially with the classical
interaction
the reduction likely works in the
quantum setting so now we're allowing
our
our
black box that is the adversary to
interact
um and send messages back and forth but
the messages have to be classical
once you allow quantum messages all bets
are off
um okay so i'll just briefly
mention that we uh
you know nevertheless even though our
particular scheme was insecure against
quantum
attacks uh you you can still
consider other schemes uh so the
question is can we
construct a fully quantum secure
encryption scheme
uh and it sort of depends on the
definition
some definitions are unattainable
there's a tax no matter what you do
uh but then there are other ways to
actually sort of
formalize everything where you actually
get an attainable definition that makes
sense for encrypting
uh quantum messages and and here's just
uh you know one example of how how you
might do this
um basically what you do is you apply a
pairwise independent function to your
message
and i i won't prove this basically the
way you prove it is you can sort of look
at the
you can look at the density matrix or
something like that of what the cyber
text looks like and
and and see that it hides all contents
of the message
uh but maybe maybe uh you know at a more
intuitive level
um the the scheme from before xored with
the message you can think of that as
um sort of one wise independence
and as is often the case when going from
classical to quantum
you know once turn into twos so instead
of a one wise independent function you
need a two wise independent function
um so i'll leave it at that
um maybe i'll pause to see if there are
any
questions
um well i i was asking a question about
uh
uh what why not you know multiple runs
with classical interaction like why
why doesn't uh why why why shouldn't
classical security proofs you know lift
the quantum ones in that case but uh
um um um andrea says the the issue is
probably rewinding
yeah and that's going to be the next
example ah thanks thanks thanks
yes so so with that uh let's start the
next example
um so here we're going to look at the
the case of something called a
commitment so commitment is sort of the
digital analog of a locked box
so to run the commitment algorithm you
have a message
you choose some random coins and
you feed them into the commitment scheme
and out comes uh
another string called the commitment
there's a hiding property that we won't
discuss which
asks that the um the commitment hides
the message
but the more important thing for our
purposes is going to be binding
which says that um if i give you the
locked box if i give you c
the the commitment um that i can't later
pretend that i committed to something
else
um so so we say that com is
computationally binding
if it's infeasible for a here we will
start in the classical setting if it's
infeasible for an efficient classical
adversary
to find a collision to find two messages
um
and randomnesses that map to the same
commitment
if you could do this then you can um
sort of um
you can cheat basically and you know
send your one commitment and then later
pretend that you
committed to you know two to either of
two different messages
but by insisting on computational
binding we
you can't do this is the hope
that there's no way to open the
commitment to two different things
so the question is what do commitments
look like in the quantum setting
uh and the natural thing you might try
to do is just do the same
thing we did before and you replace all
instances of classical with quantum
um so you just replace your classical
polynomial time adversary with a quantum
polynomial time adversary but the
adversary's goal is the same to produce
two messages and randomnesses that map
to the same commitment
it turns out that this actually won't
work though
or it's not sufficient and and uh to
motivate this consider the following
um coin tossing application of
commitments so alice and bob
want to um establish a random
bit between the two of them uh
but they don't trust each other so what
they're gonna do
is alice is going to choose a random bid
and commit to it
so she's gonna choose a random ba and
some random coins are
and send the commitment of ba using the
randomness r
um the hiding property which we didn't
discuss means that the bit ba is hidden
so bob doesn't know anything about ba
now he chooses this
random bit bb and sends it to alice
um because he doesn't know anything
about ba his bb
should be you know in uh independent of
ba
um and what we're going to do is define
the
output bit as the xor of ba and bb
so what alice does is then she says
sends ba back to bob
as well as sort of the proof that she
actually committed to ba so she sends it
or proof for an opening
so he sends the random coins r and this
allows bob to verify that
um alice didn't sort of cheat and change
her ba after seeing bb
um right and so the intuition is that
bob can't bias the output because he
doesn't know what ba is when he has to
choose bb
and alice can't bias the output because
she committed to her ba
before seeing bb
okay and in the classical setting we can
actually formalize this intuition and
then prove that alice can't bias a bit b
so let's suppose that alice wants to
force the bit to be zero
and suppose that she can cause the
output bit to be zero with
probability noticeably larger than a
half
um well what this means for her
you know half of the time bob's bid is
zero
and half the time bob's bit is one um
we know that because alice
sort of succeeds more than half the time
um she must have a good chance
of opening um to bob's bit
in both the case where the bit is zero
and one so she can
match b a to b b then she causes the
output bit to be zero
and um by the her ability to bias her
assumed ability to bias
um we know that she can basically match
bob's bit with non-trivial probability
in
in both cases
um so now what we do is we we derive a
contradiction we're going to extract
from this adversary a collision for the
commitment scheme so we
we first the way we're going to do that
is we're going to first
run the adversary a playing the role of
bob
but with um bit zero
and and you know so the adversary
outputs something
um now what we're going to do is we're
going to actually rewind the adversary
to just before
sorry to just after the adversary
committed to see
um but before anything else so we're
going to sort of go back in time
um to just after the adversary sent the
commitment to her bit
and now we're going to finish the run
again but
this time using uh pretending having bob
set his bit to be one and we'll get the
response to the adversary
and the key point is that um sort of
once once you've conditioned on the
the commitment here um both runs and
step one and step three are actually
independent um
[Music]
because you know they start from the
same state of the adversary
and we know that both runs have a
non-trivial chance of
of sort of having alice successfully
match bob's bit
and and what we see immediately is that
what we get by looking at the final
message of al
of the adversary in both steps one and
three um we get exactly a collision we
get
you know the op we get two openings to
the commitment c
uh but with different bits um with and
and because they're independent the
probability is just multiplying we get
uh
a non-negligible chance of of succeeding
uh but what happens in the quantum
setting uh well in the quantum setting
we can do step one that's fine
uh but now when we try to do step two
we're in trouble
um and the reason is that um a is now a
quantum attacker
and they're keeping a quantum state as
they're going so they have some quantum
memory and some quantum state in that
memory as they're going
and every time we extract something from
the adversary in particular when we
extract the final message from the
adversary
this is a classical string and so in
order to extract
this classical string from the outer
series quantum state a measurement had
to happen
um but this measurement means that the
adversary state is irreversibly altered
and so we can't at least in a
computationally efficient manner we
can't return
to the adversary state at a prior point
in time it's been destroyed
uh and so we're so we're in trouble um
and and and this can be formalized
um and so there's this uh theorem by
venus
rose manus and unrw um that basically
shows
relative to a quantum oracle that there
there is a commitment that is post
quantum binding meaning you can't find a
collision um but for which alice can
nevertheless break the coin tossing game
um so it's not just an issue with the
proof technique you know there really is
a barrier here
um so so because of this
we need to you know when we're trying to
expand
our our key takeaway we need to be
careful
uh so here here i'll give sort of the
final version
of it which is as long as the reduction
treats a as a single run black box
potentially allowing for classical
interaction um the reduction likely
works in the quantum setting
um but again if interactions quantum all
bets are off
and now also if we ever have to rewind
the adversary
all bets are off um and this is true
you know here we're never considering
quantum interaction
is we're only focusing on classical
interaction and yet
um and yet there's a problem so it
really is crucial that um we treat a as
a single run for this
um so i'm sort of running out of time
but
i'll just briefly mention that there
there is a solution
to this um and the
uh the idea basically is to enhance
the um the
commitment scheme maybe i'll just
skip through this but it so one thing is
that it turns out that if your scheme is
perfectly binding
um then actually everything works
and the reason is is that um
the the opening that alice sends
is actually uniquely determined by the
commitment
and so it what that means is that we
didn't actually have to do any
measurements to extract
the the opening from alice by the fact
that the opening was a valid opening of
the commitment
um it's already been uniquely determined
it basically already has been measured
and collapsed
um sort of implicitly um so
uh uh so we can actually then run
through the proof obtain a collision
which thereby
contradicts perfect binding um
uh now perfect binding isn't always um
isn't always good uh so perfect planning
means there just doesn't exist
any collisions um and therefore your
commitment actually has to be
larger than the message for this bit
flipping example that's not a big deal
but in other settings it's a problem
um so a better definition is something
called
collapsing which more or less just
directly captures um what we need which
is the ability to
measure um alice's opening without her
detecting that we measured the opening
and if you can do that if if their
commitment team has the property that
you can measure the opening without
[Music]
without detection then you can get the
proof to go through
and as a result of this collapse binding
has become sort of the standard goal for
post-quantum
uh commitments um
and then uh okay so so so we know that
we can achieve this coin tossing
with a collapse binding commitment and
then the last bit is
just how do we um how do we build these
things
and the and it takes some some effort
um there's a there's a theorem by unruly
that random oracles
uh so truly random function is collapse
binding
um and then in some other work it was
shown that you can construct clamps
binding commitments from lattices
but the point is that these these proofs
have to be in
sort of inherently quantum proofs now
because our definition for the quantum
security of a commitment scheme is now
actually a quantum definition like we're
actually
the the goal of the adversary is a
quantum uh
you know they're actually sending
quantum information they're sending you
know they're
getting a quantum opening and
asking whether it's um measured or not
um so so these arguments have to be
inherently quantum
uh and so a key takeaway from this is
that even if you're only worried about
attacks over classical channels
um sometimes you need to consider
security under some quantum interaction
notion like a collapse finding
commitment
um okay so so in the last couple of
minutes i'll just um
talk about the the fourth example which
is something called the random oracle
model
uh so uh the random oracle model
is motivated as follows so many
cryptosystems out there
make use of a cryptographic hash
function
um but it turns out that we don't know
how to prove many of these secure
just under the assumption that the hash
function is i don't know collision
resistant or one way or something like
that
um and so uh the
common practice now is to pretend
that the hash function is actually you
know so well designed that it basically
acts like a random function um
or a random oracle so the cryptosystems
they just evaluate the hash
on various inputs so they can sort of uh
they
already treat the hash function like a
random oracle and the uh the
assumption is essentially that the
adversary also treats the hash function
like around oracle that they don't gain
any advantage
by looking at the program code
so when we
move to the quantum setting uh the
question is what happens in the random
oracle model
um and the the um the point i guess is
that
in the real world that there isn't a
random numerical random oracles don't
exist in the real world in the real
world it's a concrete hash function
and the adversary can certainly query
this concrete hash function on
superpositions of inputs
to you know run grover's algorithm or or
the bht algorithm for finding collisions
and so the only way to sensibly capture
the um
adversaries that may try to run grover's
algorithm
or whatnot is to allow
our adversary quan when we're sort of in
this switching to the pretend world
where our
our hash function is replaced by random
oracle um
we we allow the adversary to make
quantum queries to the random one
the only way that we can sensibly
capture
attacks of this form and so this has now
become sort of the standard
goal and the random oracle model for
post quantum crypto
is to to justify security when you make
quantum interaction to the random oracle
uh but it turns out that the the
classical proofs don't carry over to the
quantum
random oracle even if the the goal
was um sort of a definition with
classical interaction so even if your
encryption scheme even if you're only
targeting post quantum security
there's no rewinding no quantum
interaction or anything like that
it turns out that the proof still
doesn't carry over to the quantum
setting
because the our modeling of the
adversary yeah sure it's interacting
with the challenger making classical
queries
but the adversary is now making quantum
queries to the random oracle
so um because of because the even if the
experiment is a classical experiment
we're modeling our adversary as a
adversary with quantum interaction um
and you know based on everything we've
just talked about
once you have quantum interact once your
adversary is allowed quantum interaction
the classical security proofs um
generally don't work and the bad news is
there are actually some negative results
they won't
say what this means but there you know
there are cases where the
uh contrived cases where the quantum
mechanical fails
um but the good news is that um most
major results have been
reproved um
okay i guess i have one more thing
before we end um
which is that there is actually a silver
lining to all of this
and this was this was some work by
myself
and some co-authors um where we actually
observed that um these these bad
cases these sort of cases where the
classical proofs don't lift to the
quantum setting
actually can be turned around and turned
into useful things
uh um and and in particular you know the
the setting of a post quantum commitment
scheme where the coin tossing
game is insecure um actually leads to
novel applications such as quantum money
and other things like this
and the the intuition is that if you can
win the coin tossing game
and yet the commitment scheme is post
quantum secure
essentially that implies that the
adversary has a quantum state and it's
done clone well if it's if it were a
clonable then you could
um you could sort of skip the rewinding
step and use the two clones in the
in the two executions in steps one and
three
um so the the uh so
the fact that the adversary can win
while
um the commitment scheme is post quantum
secure
means that the adversary state is
quantum and unclonable
and you can actually leverage this you
can turn you can take a supposed
adversary and actually
use that adversary to build a new
cryptosystem um where they basically
prove to some other party that they have
a quantum
and unclonable state and this gives you
um you know novel applications like
um quantum money and so forth um so
there is a there is a silver lining to
all this that i just wanted to mention
um and now i am done and uh the summary
for my talk
is that uh post quantum crypto is more
than just lattices
you know really there's a sort of a rich
landscape
of things that need to be solved um
from you know underlying computational
assumptions
understanding the right security
definitions to
um you know actually updating our
classical proofs to give
proofs that make sense in the quantum
setting
and so with that i will finish my talk
thanks a lot mark thanks for this uh
the great talk um let's see we are
we are now uh uh
going to start our panel uh so mark if
you could stop
sharing your screen oh great so
um so we have a we have a and
sorry before we before we start with the